- Legal Eagle is coming in loud
and clear thanks to Ting Mobile.
Neither snow nor rain nor heat nor gloom
of night stays postal
workers from their jobs
but they never met President Donald Trump.
And now is there a postal conspiracy
to slow down mail to
affect the 2020 election.
2020 will go down in
history as a year dominated
by the coronavirus pandemic.
But in case you haven't noticed,
we also have a major election coming up
in just a few short months
and COVID-19 spreads easily between people
who are in close contact endorsed
so states are scrambling for alternatives
to packing people into
polling places like sardines
and people are worried so
this has led to a shortage
of poll workers.
The best solution according
to the Centers for Disease Control
is to increase voting by mail.
And I have an entire video
devoted to voting by mail
and the potential for mail
fraud if there is one.
But consistent with the
CDC's recommendation,
several states have expanded
the ability of voters
to vote absentee or by mail.
As a result of these changes,
a record 76% of American
voters will be eligible
to receive a ballot in the mail
for the November 2020 election.
Now it's not entirely
clear because he flip-flops
but it appears that President Trump
is against voting by mail.
- [Donald] Now they
need that money in order
to have the post office work.
So it can take all of
these millions and millions
of ballots but if they
don't get those two items,
that means you can't have
universal mail and voting.
- And we can only speculate
as to why that is.
And into this mess,
jumped new postmaster General Louis DeJoy.
The man with the surname that sounds like
it should be a candy bar
is making sweeping changes
at the postal service.
These changes include reducing staff,
taking away blue mailboxes,
prohibiting overtime
and raising postage on ballots
and throwing away mail sorters
which this reporter caught on video.
- We are at the USPS, Patterson
location where behind me,
you can see a graveyard
of mail sorting pieces.
They're just large pieces of machinery
that had been yanked out.
In addition to that, there's
also a dumpster right there.
And according to an employee
that works across the way
they tell me that that dumpster
has been billed three times
since last week with parts and pieces
of what we're being told are
the mail sorting machines.
- The postal service has now warn
that states may not be
able to deliver ballots
in time for the November
election or deliver the ballots
that are in fact cast.
And despite the fact that
President Trump has tweeted
that we should save the post
office, though not recognizing
that he is sort of the guy in charge.
It appears that President Trump is opposed
to increasing funding for the
USPS and ensuring that ballots
are delivered on time.
Coincidence or conspiracy?
Hey, Legal Eagles, it's
time to think like a lawyer
because the USPS may hang in the balance.
Today we're gonna take a
close look at what's happening
at the postal services.
Louis DeJoy deliberately
trying to impact the outcome
of the election by slowing down the mail.
And if so, can he be stopped?
But first let's talk
about the actual structure
of the US post office.
The USPS delivers 40% of the world's mail.
However, COVID-19 caused
a significant reduction
in letter mail which is the
most profitable mail process
by the post office.
And the COVID-19 crisis
could not have happened
at a worst time for the us post office.
The volume of letter
mail has been decreasing
for quite some time mostly due
to the availability of email
and other options for
communicating quickly.
To understand the current
issues we have to review
the basic legal structure
of the US post office.
The post office was established in 1775
and the US post office was
actually a cabinet level agency
until 1970 when Congress passed
the Postal Reorganization
Act which established
the United States Postal Service
as a quasi independent
self funded organization.
President George W. Bush signed
the Postal Accountability
and Enhancement Act in 2006.
The PAEA was the first broad
revision of the 1970 statute.
The PAEA imposed several new requirements
on how the postal service is allowed
to conduct it's business.
Section 101 of the PAEA
a defines postal service
to mean the delivery of
letters, printed matter
or mailable packages
including acceptance collection sorting,
transportation or other
functions ancillary there to.
This section of the law
clarifies and limits
what the postal service can do.
Prior to this law, the post office used
to sell things like prepaid
phone cards for example
but this practice ended after the payout
because the sale of prepaid phone cards
did not fit within this definition.
This was good news for the
post office competitors
but bad news for the post
office's ability to self fund.
And section 102 of the law
is a blanket prohibition
on new products that aren't mail.
Several postmaster
generals have complained
that the postal service isn't permitted
to legally offer banking,
cell phone logistics
and other services the postal services
and other countries use to
generate the income necessary
to offset the cost of their
universal service obligation.
Senator Bernie Sanders has suggested
that the post office be allowed
to provide basic banking services.
- Postal service can make
billions of dollars a year
by establishing basic banking services.
So lower income people have access.
- But this can't happen without
congressional intervention.
Under title two of the
PAEA, the postal service
can only offer two categories of products,
market dominant products
and competitive products.
The postal services
market dominant products
include things like
first class mail letters,
first class mail cards and media mail.
With these monopolistic products,
the USPS can only increase
prices in accordance
with the consumer price index.
This keeps the rates down for consumers
but contributes to the
postal services insolvency.
But given the USPS has a
monopoly on these products,
there's a reason why you don't
necessarily want the prices
to increase too dramatically.
But competitive products include those
for which a competitive
market already exists.
Those include things like
priority mail, expedited mail
and bulk parcel post.
For these competitive products,
the post office is barred from
offering prices lower than
the cost of delivery.
So this means that the USPS
can't undercut FedEx and USPS
by offering dramatically lower prices
that are below the cost
of actually delivering.
And again, this benefits consumers
but hurts the post office's
ability to fund itself
or offer lost leaders.
The PAEA also established
the postal service retiree
health benefits fund.
Section 801 to 803 of the
PAEA had changed the USPS
from funding its retirees healthcare costs
on a pay as you go basis to
pre-funding these obligations.
The upshot of this is that
the post office had to create
a $72 billion fund to pay for the cost
of its post retirement health care cost.
And the fact that the postal
service has to pre-fund
its retirement obligations
from a separate account,
hampers its financial prospects
and this pre-funding burden applies
to no other federal agency
and no private employer.
Now the PAEA also created the
Postal Regulatory Commission.
Now the PRC, no relation,
has significant powers
but it also has to follow the requirements
of the Administrative
Procedures Act or APA.
We've talked about the
APA a lot on this channel
but it governs the process
by which federal agencies
develop regulations.
It includes requirements
for publishing notices
of proposed and final rulemaking
in the federal register
and provides opportunities for the public
to comment on notices
of proposed rulemaking.
The APA also requires most rules
to have a 30 day delayed effective date.
The APA provides standards
for judicial review
if a person has been adversely affected
or aggrieved by an agency.
So if the postal rate commission
maybe sweeping changes
without following the
APA and spoiler alert,
they did these changes
could be rolled back
by a federal court.
And as an aside, a lot of people ask
why doesn't the postal
service run like a business.
And many people have
argued that the post office
isn't profitable, they claim that
if it was any other business
like the Trump Taj Mahal
it would have declared bankruptcy
because it couldn't turn a profit.
And in fact, Trump appointee
Richard Grinnell says that
the post office should
just charge you a lot more
to send letters and packages
to make the USPS profitable.
And Senator Rand Paul
says that rural citizens
such as many of the people
that he represents in Kentucky
should just settle for receiving
the mail just three days a week.
And those changes could help make
the postal service more profitable.
But the postal service has legal mandate
to provide universal
service to all US addresses
without charging more for
more costly delivery routes.
And this is known
as the Universal Service
Obligation or USO.
The USO is not clearly
defined in legislation
but it's pieced together from
numerous laws and regulations.
And the basic obligations
of the postal service
are defined in 39 USC
sections 101 and 403.
These statutes require the post office
to provide a range of product offerings,
maintain uniform prices and availability,
provide efficient services to people
in every geographic location in the US
and make its facilities
accessible to everyone.
Congress gave the post office
a monopoly on mail service
in exchange for providing
all of these service benefits
to the American people uniformly
in both price and service.
And under 39 USC section
404D, small post offices
may not be closed solely
for operating at a deficit.
If the post office was legally allowed
to operate like any other business,
it could eliminate thousands
of unprofitable post offices
in rural areas, it could cut
services to rural citizens,
it could only deliver the
mail three days a week
and it can charge much more
for different service routes.
Now like many crises during the Trump era,
these problems began long
before President Trump took office
but the President has
exploited some of these issues
and accelerated them.
The board of governors of
the USPS is responsible
for overseeing the activities
of the postal service
while the postmaster
general actively manages
its day to day operations.
A postmaster general is not
appointed by the president
instead the board of
governors chooses a new person
only when there's a vacancy
and the board of governors
is designed to be as
nonpartisan as possible.
For this reason, no more than five members
can be members of the
same political party.
However, right now there
are only six members
of the board of governors
and all six of them
were appointed by President Trump.
The other vacancies have not been filled,
presumably because
President Trump is required
by law to appoint Democrats.
The board of governors
has not been fully staffed
since 2010 because
Senate Republicans refuse
to confirm five nominees
by President Obama.
In April, the USPS notified Congress
that it was running out of money
and in May, Repubican donor Louis DeJoy
was named postmaster general
by the now six members
of the board of governors.
President Trump asked his
nominees who were the only people
on the board to appoint DeJoy.
They did so despite his lack of experience
at the postal service,
he is the first postmaster general ever
to have zero experience with the USPS.
He was most recently
the financial chairman
of the Republican National Committee.
DeJoy hasn't divested himself
of his financial holdings
and a logistics company that does business
with the postal service.
He also went out and
purchased Amazon stock
after his nomination as postmaster general
which is a potential red flag
for conflict of interest.
And speaking of Amazon,
the company does have a
great deal with the USPS.
The retail giant focuses
its own delivery network
on densely populated urban
areas which keeps its costs low.
However, this means
that the postal service
which is required to serve everyone
effectively winds up
subsidizing Amazon delivery
to low population density areas.
The address is that it
wouldn't be profitable
for Amazon to deliver
to which coincidentally
are very, very red counties
across the country.
And ironically Republicans,
including President Trump
have criticized the Amazon
deal as being bad for business.
And in spite of or perhaps
because of this relationship
with Amazon, President Trump has disagreed
with various Democratic
proposals to increase funding
for the post office.
So let's talk about the recent
changes that DeJoy brought
to the US postal service.
On July 10th, DeJoy announced
a major operational pivot
which imposes new significant
restrictions on the timing
and nature of letter carrier routes.
DeJoy admitted that
this would cause delays
in the memo where he said,
we may see mail left behind
or mail on the workroom
floor which is not typical.
And just to be clear, DeJoy also says
he didn't make any of these
controversial changes.
- Could you please tell me
who did order these changes
if you as postmaster general did not?
- There were many, many executives
almost 30,000 executives
within the organization.
And there were plans that
existed prior to my arrival
that will continue that were implemented.
- But postal workers have been trained
not to leave letters
behind, make multiple trips
to ensure timely distribution of the mail.
This is why they sometimes
make unscheduled deliveries
or deliver mail on a Sunday.
DeJoy now says that carriers
leave this mail behind
for the next day which
may accumulate and pile up
as time goes on.
In addition, letter
carriers are now prohibited
from sorting mail in the morning
and delivering it in the afternoon.
Instead, they will get
to the routes earlier
in the morning and then
return to their posts
to sort mail in the afternoon.
And some of these policies
directly effect ballot delivery.
On July 29th, the USPS
general council announced
a policy change directly
targeting balance.
Letters said that the ballot
sent by marketing mail
would not be accorded
first class mail treatment
and thus take longer to deliver.
The postal service had
previously trained as employees
to give first-class treatment to balance
in any other election related materials
sent as marketing mail.
This change imposes much bigger
financial burdens on states
which will now have to
pay 55 cents per piece
for first class delivery rather
than the 20 cents per piece
they previously paid.
States are already
anticipating huge increases
in requests for ballots.
This comes at a time when state budgets
are completely in shambles
because of COVID-19.
In addition, postal clerks
can no longer provide
a witness signature on balance
and some states you need
a third party witness
when you sign a mailed ballot.
And the ballots typically say that voters
can simply go to the post office
and have a worker watch them sign
that this practice is now ended.
And one of the most baffling measures
has been the decommissioning of 10%
of the mail sorting machines
at postal service centers.
These machines can sort 30,000
pieces of mail per hour.
And although DeJoy said that
he would stop doing this,
they've already decommissioned
95% of the machines
that were planned to be disconnected.
In August DeJoy ordered the postal service
to remove 671 mail sorting
machines by the end of September
including 24 in Ohio, 11
in Detroit, 11 in Florida,
nine in Wisconsin, eight in Philadelphia
and five in Arizona.
What's interesting about these states
is that these just happened to be states
which are expected to decide the outcome
of the presidential election.
And DeJoy who claims he
didn't make these changes
has a firm opinion on whether
he would ever reverse them.
- Mr. DeJoy will you commit
to reversing these changes?
- No.
- These actions have already
spurred nationwide mail delays
in mail collection, mail
sorting and mail delivery.
And a mail processing facility
in Santa Clarita in July,
workers discovered that their
automated sorting machines
had been disabled and padlocked.
At a large mail sorting
facility in Los Angeles,
workers told the LA Times
that they are so far
behind processing packages
that by early August, nats
and rodents were swarming
around containers of
rotted fruit and meat.
And a brief warning to animal lovers,
there were even some packages
containing small animals
which perished in their boxes.
In Southeast Washington DC,
residents have gone weeks
without receiving any mail.
- People have medical supplies
that are delivered by the mail.
They have utility bills,
they have important financial documents.
- Which they are not receiving
and I can say personally
that one of the mailboxes
that has been in my own
neighborhood in Washington DC
which has been there
for years if not decades
was recently removed just a few weeks ago
and I've never received
an explanation why.
There've been many reports of veterans
and elderly citizens who
rely on mail delivery
of their medication, going through delays
and entire native American
tribes in California
haven't received mail for weeks.
So not surprisingly, this
has created all kinds
of legal battles.
Voters, states, advocacy
groups and candidates
are suing the Trump
administration over changes
at the postal service.
The NAACP filed a lawsuit
against DeJoy and Trump,
the NAACP is main cause of action
is that the postal service ignored
the postal reorganization act by failing
to seek an advisory opinion from the PRC
under 39 USC section 3661
before implementing changes
that have a nationwide
impact on mail delivery.
The postal service has
to provide an opportunity
for public comment and
seek in advisory opinion
from the postal rate commission.
The opinion may not issue
until the commission provides
an opportunity for public hearing.
And here it's undisputed that
the postal service failed
to do so with respect to either the pivot
or the change in treatment of ballots sent
by marketing mail.
And Congress also mandates
that the postal service shall give
the highest consideration
to the requirement
for the most expeditious
collection, transportation
and delivery of important letter mail.
The NAACP argues that the
postal services reversal
of its policy of according
first class service
to ballots sent by marketing
mail is inconsistent
with that statutory mandate.
And it's also obvious
that DeJoy's changes violated the APA.
The biggest question is
whether a court will order him
to reverse course and remediate the steps
that have already been taken.
Others argue that this
violates the elections clause
and the electors clause
of the constitution.
Pennsylvania, Maine, California, Delaware,
the District of Columbia,
Massachusetts and North Carolina
have filed a lawsuit against
the federal government
raising many of the same
claims as the NAACP.
In addition, the state's
alleged that DeJoy actions
are unconstitutional under
the elections clause.
The constitution elections
clause vests authority
in the states to regulate
the quote time place
and manner of holding
elections for senators
and representatives that
will represent the state.
But only Congress may displace how a state
has chosen to regulate the time place
and manner of a federal election.
The constitution electors
clause vest authority
in the states to a point, quote,
" A number of electors
equal to the whole number
"of senators and representatives
to which the state
"may be entitled in Congress."
The plaintiff's states here
alleged they've exercised
these rights by expanding voting by mail.
When they pass legislation
that expanded vote by mail,
they relied on the postal
services long history
in delivering election
mail in a timely manner.
They contend that DeJoy
abrupt changes interfere
with the constitutional
power given to the states
to control their own elections
and other alleged violations of the first
and 14th amendments.
Certain voters have the
Trump administration
and DeJoy actions arguing
that they are being denied
their right to vote.
And these suits the plaintiff's alleged
that the way DeJoy is
managing the postal service
will stop some voters from voting at all
which would be a severe burden.
Plaintiffs include people
who have medical conditions
that make COVID-19 especially dangerous
and people who live in remote areas
and cannot travel long
distances to vote in person.
And theoretically, if a
burden would essentially deny
a person in the right to vote,
then it could be considered
though others would argue that
everyone faces some burden
in voting, it's simply a spectrum here.
But the plaintiffs in these
suits say that the government
doesn't have any real estate interest
in making the dramatic changes.
And the only interest
that postmaster DeJoy
has identified as cost
saving and efficiency.
Plaintiffs argue that while cost saving
is important in government in
many ways, it's settled law
that constitutional rights
cannot be taken away
because it's too expensive to grant them.
In addition, the postal services mandate
to serve as an affordable
public service seems to clash
with the idea that
cost-savings should interfere
with constitutional rights.
The plaintiffs also note
that the president stated justification
for denying post office funding
his own political fortunes
is obviously not the kind of
legitimate government interest
that would justify a burden
on voters and candidates.
But some of the damage
has already been done
and unfortunately, the courts
will be relatively slow to act
and reports continue
that the postal service
is removing blue postal
boxes all over the country.
If you see this happening, you
should report it immediately
and to do that, you'll need
really good cell coverage.
And Ting Mobile is just
the cellular service
to report governmental misconduct.
Ting provides great LTE coverage
because it partners with
the biggest carriers.
So you got the benefit
of three massive networks
wherever you go, no matter which part
of the state you live in.
And these days, the
smartphone with a camera
is the greatest tool we have
against government oppression
and Ting Mobile lets you send those videos
of government corruption
quickly and efficiently.
Because taking mobile
is a different kind of mobile rider,
with Ting, you only
pay for the actual data
and services that you use
at the end of the month
and because you're paying for
only what you actually use,
Ting customers on average
just $23 per month
for one device.
And with Ting, you can
use almost any cell phone
including the newest
iPhones and pixel phones
and you can use the same phone number
you're using right now.
There's no contract overage fees
or any other carrier tricks.
You just pay a fair
price for the talk text
and data that you use up
at the end of the month.
And Ting has award-winning
customer support.
Because they don't have any
brick and mortar stores,
they pour all their resources
into their phone and online support.
If you have any issues, you
can just pick up the phone,
call them and immediately
talk to a real human being.
With Ting especially if you're
around wifi all the time
which most of us are considering
we're working from home
which is why we need to vote
by mail in the first place,
you ended up paying less than you do now.
Of course, some people
should pay $200 a month
for unlimited data if they're nowhere near
their homes or wifi but
if you're surrounded
by wifi network all day long,
you might be paying hundreds of dollars
more completely unnecessarily
and Ting gives you the option
to pay only for what you use.
So if you go to legaleagle.ting.com,
you can use your last bill
to compare just how much you would save.
And Legal Eagles will get a $25 credit
by going to legaleagle.ting.com
and that could cover your
entire first month of service.
And since there are no
contracts, you can try it
for a month, no strings attached.
Again, all you have to
do is click on the link
in the description or go
to legaleagle.ting.com
and get a $25 credit for
whatever service you want.
Plus clicking on that link
really helps out this channel.
So do you agree with my analysis?
Do you think that the
USPS is being destroyed
from the inside?
Leave your objections in the comments
and check out the playlist over here
with all of the other real law reviews,
talking about all of the
crazy things that's happening
in the government on
the run up to election.
So that's fun.
So click on this playlist
and I'll see you in court.